ich bin leer offizier für km schwimmen
und tauchen beim österreichischen
bundesheer und ich würde jetzt gerne was
auch erklären zur rettungsaktion der
kinder in der höhle in thailand diese
rettungsaktion hat einige
schwierigkeiten aus taktischer sicht und
da können wir vom bundesheer auch ein
paar fachexperten dazu abgeben
zunächst einmal muss man berücksichtigen
dass die kinder jetzt nahezu drei wochen
an extremen psychischen stress
ausgesetzt worden
sie seien körperlich sehr geschwächt bzw
geschwächt gewesen und die medizinischen
komponente spricht der fallende
sauerstoffgehalt in der höhle hat ein
zusätzliches getan
zu den umständen dass sie drei wochen
einer feuchtigkeit ausgesetzt worden
kennen wir aus erfahrung sagen zb dem
kampf den wir gelegentlich durch führen
dass sich die haut sehr sehr aufrecht
und diese natürliche schutzfunktion
verliert wo durch pilze viren und
bakterien sehr sehr leicht eindringen
können
das heißt diese grund schwächung haben
die kinder von haus aus jetzt schon
zusätzlich kommt dass die bergungsaktion
aus der höhle in abschnitten tauchend
erfolgen muss was für die konfiguration
der retter der rettungstaucher eine
besondere herausforderung stellt weil
die höhlen abschnitte nur durch eine
person
und selbst dort nicht mit vollem
equipment durchdacht werden können
dieses muss vorher abgelegt und vor sich
her geschoben oder nachgezogen werden
die rettungsaktion der kinder ist
erfolgt mittels einer sogenannten voll
gesichtsmaske
wir haben hier selbst eine vor ort die
wir erproben heute wieder aufsetzen
der vorteil von solchen her voll
gesichtsmasken ist jener dass sie im
falle dieser kinder nicht abgenommen
oder sehr schwer abgenommen werden
können
in panik reaktionen zusätzlich wurden
die kinderleicht zitiert sprich mit
beruhigungsmitteln behandelt dass sie
diese rettungsaktion die durch die
beiden retter vorne und hinten
durchgeführt wird kaum oder minimalem
stress ausgesetzt sind und das ganze
sehr gut vonstatten gehen kann
fertig zum tauchgang was dann
der kamerad mit der voll gesichtsmaske
wird jetzt unter wasser im trüben wasser
der alten wert von burg ist eine
ausrüstungs konfiguration überprüfen
für die heutige rettungsaktion der
kinder in thailand wünschen wir von den
bundesämtern und das gesamte bundesheer
gutes gelingen